you don't need to go far
or speculate
to know or predict what the Maga right
is going to do tonight and tomorrow and
over the next few days when it comes to
the election results they are going to
claim fraud
how do we know this because they're
telling us much like we figured out in
the summer of 2020 that the Trump
campaign was going to be claiming fraud
over mail-in ballots and other things in
the 2020 election
they're telling us they're going to do
it here is Trump lawyer Christina Bob
who also is an anchor on the right wing
channel right side broadcasting this is
last night in Vandalia Ohio and she says
if any results are delayed Beyond early
in the morning tomorrow morning they are
going to claim fraud listen to this we
do have a better chance of knowing who
won and who lost an election I think so
I expect to know who won by like the
middle of the night maybe very very
early Wednesday morning if we don't and
if Democrats try to extend the vote I
think they're going to have a very a
very hard time doing it with any level
of credibility all right now did you see
what she just did there
she did she slipped something in that's
totally incoherent she says if we don't
have the results early tomorrow morning
and Democrats try to extend the vote no
one is this is no one's extending the
vote okay extending the vote is allowing
more time for people to vote
it's that's not even at issue here okay
she's already mixing two different
things and they love to do this
one thing is just allowing people to
continue to the rules are clear
um you have to get your absentee ballots
in
if you're in line at the time that polls
close you're allowed to vote and beyond
that that's it separately there's the
issue of how quickly your votes counted
and we'll get back to that in a moment
in 2020 they were able to do it because
they claimed covid and they had this
excuse which we all know was baloney
because they had to go find more ballots
and do all of their ballot harvesting
none of that happened that's that's just
a lie there's no evidence for that
whatsoever
but I think that's going to be really
hard to do tomorrow because everybody
knows like you should be able there's no
reason you can't have a tally and for a
state let's say there's four million
voters in Michigan or Ohio and they get
through three and a half million by
midnight you're telling me you can't get
through another half a million in a
couple hours I mean it's a no-brainer
yeah now what she doesn't mention is
that the reason that in a lot of the
states they stop counting at a certain
time or it takes a long time is because
of rules that Republican legislatures
and secretaries of State have put in
place many states as a result of laws
enabled by Republican legislatures
aren't allowed to even start counting
mail-in ballots until after the polls
close you could have the mail-in ballots
counted as they come in or at designated
times you could say okay on November 7th
we'll count everything that's come in
and we'll get a very good jump start on
getting those final numbers Republican
legislatures in many cases say we don't
touch we don't count anything until the
polls close in other states the
legislatures decide you stop counting at
a certain time 10 11 pm midnight and you
don't start until the next day no matter
how close you are so Christina Bob now
wants to make it make it seem it's very
suspicious I mean listen if you're
almost done counting at midnight just
keep counting they pass laws saying that
you can't do that
and it is almost certain that I listen
we we have to know what to expect if
Pennsylvania is close and it may be very
Shapiro is going to easily defeat
mastriano but Oz fetterman could be very
close we could be talking about hundreds
or thousands of votes making the
difference
when they stop counting
we're not going to know
and there's not going to be anything
inherently suspicious about that these
are the rules that the state legislature
put in place so they are telling us what
they're planning to do
they are going to use this to try to
steal some races as they did in 2020 and
we have to be prepared there's two
things from a legal standpoint Democrats
have to be prepared to prevent
Shenanigans but from an emotional
standpoint we all have to be ready not
to react when they go oh it's so
suspicious they brought in ham
sandwiches at 11 30 it was the wrong
number of sandwiches and there were two
Orthodox Jews and they still brought ham
and that's very suspicious it's probably
because fetterman stole it right we have
to remember these these people they're
nuts okay and not to get fired up we
know what the processes are in States
like this we went through the
Pennsylvania thing two years ago and not
to allow them to rile us up
but they're going to try they're going
to claim fraud Carrie Lake will claim
fraud in Arizona she'll just claim
victory if we don't know the results uh
if she doesn't win they're going to do
it they're telling us that they're going
to do it plastic is everywhere we look
and not enough is being done about it
100 billion plastic bags are used and
thrown away every year but you can help
make a change our sponsor hold on makes
trash and kitchen bags that are heavy
duty plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
holdon bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below